HENG-TZE CHENG:
So hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming to the talk.
My name is Heng-Tze.
You can call me Heng.
I work at Google Research.
And today I'm very excited
to tell you all about Wide
and Deep Learning and how you
can use it to combine the power
of Memorization+Generalization
on TensorFlow.
At Google, we started the Wide
and Deep project with a mission
to combine the power of
memorization and generalization
on one unified machine
learning platform for everyone.
And when we say, everyone,
we really mean not
just every product
team at Google,
but also, everyone in the
open source community,
everyone in academia,
as well as industry.
So we started working
towards this mission
by jointly training Wide Linear
Models on the left and Deep
Neural Networks on the
right, and create an easy
to use API, high-level API,
available in TensorFlow,
so users can start with
simple linear models
and gradually add
complexity without ever
having to leave the platform.
So the first question
is, what do we really
mean by memorization
and generalization?
And to answer that--
before we dive into
machine learning,
let's take a step back to think
about how we learn as humans.
So as little kids we start
forming our knowledge
by observing everyday events.
For example, seagulls can
fly or pigeons can fly.
We're very good at memorizing
these maybe unrelated
boring facts very precisely.
But, as you can imagine,
good memorization probably
doesn't scale well
to over eight million
animal species in the world.
You're not going
to see all of them
and not going to memorize
all of their names
and whether they can fly or not.
So a very powerful step in our
learning is generalization.
By saying, animals
with wings can fly,
we're basically summarizing all
of these sparse observations
into one very compact
representation of knowledge,
and that's whether the animal
has wings or not, right?
Using these compact rules you
can generalize to many more
animals you may or may
not have seen before.
However, generalization
has its own limitations
because it doesn't
always work on all cases.
For example, penguins,
well, at least they try,
but the best they can do
is some sort of a free fall
into the ocean, right?
So the real power
lies in how we combine
the power of memorization
and generalization.
And interestingly, this is
very similar to what we observe
in the progression from a pure
wide model for memorization
to a pure deep model,
which gives us more power
in generalization, and finally,
in combining wide and deep,
which is generalization
plus memorizing exceptions,
which is saying, animals
with wings can fly,
but penguins cannot fly.
So enough with the
hypothetical animal examples.
Now let's come back to
a real world example,
and I'll walk you through it.
In this running
example we'll see
how we can apply wide, deep,
and wide and deep learning
on the Google Play apps
recommendation problem.
So suppose one of
our favorite users,
Chris, recently installed
the Priceline app.
The question we want to
ask is, which other apps
should we now recommend, right?
And one way to frame
this problem is--
to frame the recommendation
problem as Retrieval+Ranking.
So let's start from the
upper left, where I'll
walk you through a live query.
So we get a query from the users
in the recommendation system
case as the user feature plus
some contextual features maybe
at the time and so on.
And then our
retrieval system will
retrieve the relevant
items that relate
to this user and context.
And maybe, let's say, give us
hundreds of candidates, right?
The ranking module will
rank these candidates
and present the most promising
ones, the most relevant ones,
to the user.
The user takes a look at
the items on their phones.
And they can take one
of the possible actions,
like, click on the app,
install the app, and so on.
All of these are recorded in the
logs, which the learner picks
up, and trains a new model.
And this new model will power
the next iteration of ranking.
And that's a cycle of
recommendation, right.
So this talk we will focus
on how we use Wide and Deep
Learning to solve the
ranking model of this app
recommendation problem.
And the query
features, as I said,
is user and contextual features.
The item features are the
app impression features which
we show to the users phones.
And the objective we're
optimizing for is app installs.
So if the user installed
the app the label is one,
otherwise the label is zero.
OK.
So let's get started.
Now the first probably the
simplest model you can pick
is a Linear Model, or known
as logistic regression,
in this case.
So the inputs are a
bunch of features, right.
You can have the user features
installed app as Priceline,
and impression
features, which is
if we show KAYAK as
impression, what's
the likelihood of install?
So the impression app,
let's say, is KAYAK.
And we want to predict the
probability that the user will
install the app.
Now how do we generalize
memorization capability?
This can be done by adding
a Crossed Feature, which
is the end operation over
this binary base features.
So the cross feature can be,
install app as Priceline,
and impression app as KAYAK.
If both are true, what is
the likelihood of install?
And if we go into
the data and we
see a lot of correlation,
people who installed this also
installed that later, then you
can memorize this frequent co
occurrence of these features.
So crosses help you with that.
Now you might think that, well,
that's very specific, right?
How do we actually
generalize to other apps that
are not Priceline or KAYAK?
Well, one way you can do
it with Wide Linear Models
is to add less specific
features, like app categories.
So for example, if you add a
cross saying, if install app
category is travel and the
impression app category
is also travel, what is
the likelihood of user
installing that, right?
So once you learn
this, you can apply it
to other travel apps not
just Priceline or KAYAK.
Now the problem, which you
might have seen already,
is that the feature space is
very wide and very sparse.
There are millions
of apps, billions
of users, if you cross
apps with apps that's
a million times million which is
a trillion combinations, right?
So most of these user
impression app pairs will never
occur in your training data.
So how do you actually
generalize to these unseen
pairs without doing a lot of
manual feature engineering
that we did in the
last slide, right?
And remember, in many cases,
it might be hard for humans
to come up with these
really good high level,
less specific feature
crosses in the first place.
So one way to solve this to
generalize more automatically
is to use Deep Neural Network
with a dense embedding layer.
So starting from the
bottom, you still
have your base
binarized features,
which is, user
install Priceline,
and let's say, impression
app is Yelp now.
And let's say,
you've never shown--
you happen to never have
shown Yelp after people have
installed Priceline,
so you cannot memorize.
Now one way you can train this
is for each unique feature ID
you look up dense
embedding vector
and these are
initialized randomly
so initially you will
make very poor predictions
and you compare the error
between your prediction
and the ground
truth label and you
start adjusting your embedding.
So you predict
better and better.
So over time, the
embeddings will
act more like automatically
extracted features, high level
features, that very well
describe these base features.
So combined with the
hidden layers on top of it,
you can now automatically
learn complex interactions
between e-space features.
Now we've talked about
Wide and talked about Deep.
So when is Wide better
than Deep and vice versa?
So we can look into
the traffic patterns.
So on the left using
the Wide Model,
you're basically learning a
matrix to memorize which user
install app and impression app
combinations correlates with
install and which one doesn't.
The problem is there are these
question marks which means
there are no data to train on.
So if you notice that
in the rows and columns
there are a lot of repetitive
or similar structures
you can leverage.
So if you map all of
these apps onto a lower
dimensional embedding
space, on the right,
you might have that
similar apps that
will be closer to each other
in the embedding space.
So we can now generalize
your prediction
to any app in the
embedding space, right?
And in this hypothetical
example on the left,
you would need 22 floats numbers
to memorize these interactions,
whereas on the right,
you only need 20
floats to store the embeddings.
Being able to represent
the same or even richer
information using less number
of parameters, meaning you
are leveraging the structure
of the data better.
Now, on the other
hand, there are
a lot of specific user tastes,
niche apps, or just exceptions
in the app training data.
So for example, a Sheldon
Cooper Bazinka app probably
wouldn't make sense to recommend
unless the user has seen
the show, "Big Bang Theory."
So there are all these
kind of niche combinations.
And if we use a Wide Model
to memorize you can just
use five ways to memorize
this diagonal matrix
in this hypothetical
example, right?
Whereas, if you
still try to learn
a low dimensional
embedding, then you
will still need 20 floats.
And now the learner
will try very
hard to push these irrelevant
apps away from each other,
but find it very hard to do so
in a crowded low dimensional
embedding space.
And what will happen is you
will accidentally recommend
less relevant apps to the user.
And that's partly because if
you have a high rank sparse
matrix like the diagonal
matrix on the left
is, theoretically,
very hard or impossible
to find these lower
dimensional embedding that
will reconstruct the left.
OK.
So our idea is very simple.
Why not just combine the
power of Wide and Deep, right?
So we not only get the
combination of memorization
and generalization, and in
many recommendation systems
and search ranking
problems we often want
to balance relevance
versus diversity,
as well, so we satisfy
our users need.
So that's what we did.
We jointly train Wide Linear
Model and Deep Neural Network
simultaneously by back
propagating to both sides
at the same time in training.
So we connect them to the same
last function and backdrop
to both sides.
Now you might notice
that this is somewhat
similar to an Ensemble Model.
But in the Ensemble Model
you would train two models
separately without
knowing each other.
And only at prediction
time you would combine
their predictions, right?
So we've been trying both.
And what we've observe is
that doing a joint training,
because they know each
other in the training time,
the Wide Model only needs to
augment what the Deep Model
cannot learn well,
and vice versa.
So you often get a
much smaller model,
whereas if you train
ensemble, both models
need to be fairly large
and self-sufficient models
so their ensemble will
make a good prediction.
And we're definitely
actively working
on comparing the
performance of both.
And we're happy to here
what you find as well.
So this is what
we got eventually
that was launched into the
production of Google Play
apps recommendation.
So it's a three layer
neural networks on the left.
And down below, you have
your continuous feature
and categorical features
that feeds into the model.
And this is augmented by a
cross product transformation,
a cross between the user install
app and the impression app.
And both are connected
to the logistic loss
for joint training.
And we published these results
in the paper, previously.
We ran online experiments
on Google Play.
And we've seen that the Wide and
Deep Model had a significant 4%
gain on our Wide Model, which
is a very mature, highly
optimized, previous generation
model that's been used.
And we also compare it with the
Deep part of the Wide and Deep
Model, and it has a
1% gain on top of it.
And that's pretty
significant for Google Play.
Now the good news is all
these you can do today
in about 10 lines of code using
the high level estimator API,
which Martin and others
have talked about.
So all you have to do is, first,
define the features you want
to use in your Wide Models, and
configure the crosses you think
might be useful for memorizing
a lot of combinations.
And the second part,
you define the features
you want to use
in the Deep Model,
and the embedding
configurations.
And finally, define
your model structure,
like, how many hidden layers,
how wide are the hidden layers.
And boom, you can start
training right away.
So I encourage you to go online
and search for Wide and Deep
Learning to learn more
about Wide and Deep
from the resources we provide.
So we've open-sourced it.
We have blog post, paper,
a YouTube video, and also
TensorFlow tutorials to
walk you through these.
And we found it useful for
general recommendations,
search, and ranking
problems, especially
if you have sparse categorical
inputs with a large number
of unique feature values.
We're excited to learn if you
find it useful in other use
cases as well.
And finally, I think
we all want to learn
Wider and Deeper about machine
learning and maybe just
everything else.
But I think the true power
lies in the word, together.
So in the Wide and
Deep project we
brought two pretty different
modeling techniques together
on one unified platform.
And that benefited many
product teams at Google.
And by open-sourcing and
sharing our findings,
you and we are now able to
collaborate even if we're not
in the same organization.
And together, we can get
a deeper understanding
of how to combine these
machine learning technologies
with a community
that's wider than ever.
And I think that's a
very powerful thing.
So I'd like to thank
all the contributors
to the Wide and Deep Project.
And thank you very much for
listening to the talk today.
Thank you.